hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american heartwarming drama movie
called wonder this movie tells the story
of a boy named august pullman usually
called auggie he is 10 years old but he
is a special born child
he was born with a rare medical facial
deformity mandibulofacial dysostosis and
has undergone 27 surgeries in order to
see smell speak and hear normally
currently he's in elementary school but
this year his parents decided to enroll
him in middle school after four years of
homeschooling before classes begin augie
and his mother isabelle meet the
principal tushman to give an
introduction about the school
environment the principal arranges a
tour for him with three other students
jack julian and charlotte feeling
inferior he finally gets to know them
they go around the school but not long
after a curious julian asks why auggie's
face is like that the question makes an
awkward moment for them
luckily the question doesn't make augie
sad and he stays tough
at night his father nate asks him about
the introduction of the school
environment earlier his parents say it
is okay if he doesn't want to go to the
school but he still insists on going to
the school
the next morning his family including
his older sister olivia takes him to his
new school
fortunately with his condition like that
he still gets support encouragement and
also love from his family which are
things that are very necessary for him
he begins to enter the school and is
ostracized from his friends even the
noisy classroom suddenly becomes quiet
when he enters the class everyone is
staring at him strangely
in the class they start to introduce
themselves for the first time
auggie says he really likes star wars
then julian asks if his favorite
character is darth sidious with that
question he knows that it was a mockery
because the character has a face that is
similar to his during break time all his
friends keep looking at him strangely
and no one wants to sit near him
even julian again mocks him by saying
that the way he eats like a monster in
star wars movies during sports hours he
becomes the only target to throw the
ball at after school julian and his gang
bully him continuously at dinner the
family discusses how their respective
days were augie who has no intention of
discussing his first day at school
chooses to leave the table his mother
immediately follows him into his room
and asks what happened he cries because
his facial deformity makes everyone at
school doesn't want to talk to him his
mother still gives encouragement and
believes that he will easily live his
life in the future on the other hand
olivia also supports her little brother
even though since augie's existence her
parents attention has decreased for her
but she is very mature in accepting this
and understanding her family situation
her life also changes after the school
holidays she is less socialized at
school her best friend miranda has been
well received in her family but
strangely on the first day of school
something changes inside her she's
slowly getting away from olivia even
though she doesn't know what caused it
shortly after she gets a new friend
named justin because of him she signs up
for the school drama club
meanwhile augie is getting used to his
school life
he is used to the strange looks he
received as well as the bullying that
happened to him he is very interested in
science which for the other children is
the most difficult subject one day the
teacher holds a science test
seeing jack who is having trouble taking
the test he gives a free cheat so that
jack can get a good score
later jack approaches him and thanks him
for the help earlier it turns out that
good grades are very important to jack
because he is a student on a scholarship
program
they immediately became good friends
that day
for halloween auggie dresses as ghost
face from last year after his dog ruins
the boba fett costume he was going to
wear he walks through school upbeat and
confident due to his anonymity however
upon entering the classroom he overhears
jack who does not recognize him joining
julian and his friends and making fun of
him behind his back saying he would kill
himself if he looked like auggie he
becomes incredibly sad and makes himself
sick from worry forcing his mother to
abandon her mother-daughter day with
olivia to get him when he gets home
augie vents his anger on olivia but she
tells them that they have something in
common namely that they are both shunned
by their best friend in the end she
convinces augie to go trick-or-treating
soon augie forms a new friendship with a
girl named summer he confides in her
about his split with jack
when jack asks summer why auggie
suddenly is avoiding him she only says
ghostface he soon realizes and resolves
to make it up to him by being his
partner for the science fair when julian
confronts jack in the hallway and
calling augie a freak they begin
fighting as a result jack is suspended
for two days and the principal reads his
letter about defending augie
he then apologizes to augie via
minecraft telling him he said only to
gain favor with julian's friend group
and they finally reconcile
later olivia begins a relationship with
justin
she is selected as miranda's understudy
for the lead in the school's production
but on the opening night miranda learns
that olivia's family is in attendance
while her own is not consequently she
feigns illness to let olivia take her
place
she gives a moving performance earning a
standing ovation
at the end she and miranda reconciled
due to the success of the drama
augie's popularity and circle of friends
grows over the years but he is still
bullied by julian and his friends until
the teacher notices one day the
principal confronts julian and his
parents with evidence including hate
notes and a class picture with auggie
photoshopped out julian's mother admits
that she deleted augie from the picture
and defends julian's actions she also
insists the other students should not be
exposed to auggie despite her threats to
poll funding julian is suspended for two
days forcing him to miss the school trip
as they leave his mom declares that she
and her husband were going to pull their
son out of school anyway so he will not
be back in the next semester and julian
apologizes for his fault at the trip
they are very happy and participate in
various series of activities when
watching together jack feels bored and
asks augie to go out together not long
after they are threatened by a trio of
seventh graders from another school
luckily julian's ex-gang suddenly helps
them at the right time
after that jack and augie thank them one
of them says that auggie is a brave boy
and they already consider him as a good
friend
because this is the first time he
receives such a warm welcome augie is
crying for the first time he feels
accepted and becomes part of his friends
the trip changes his spirits he becomes
more confident and excited to hang out
with his friends at the graduation
ceremony augie thanks his mom for
enrolling him in school and she tells
him that he is really a wonder he is
given the henry ward beecher medal for
his strength and courage throughout the
school year the movie ends with everyone
cheering auggie as he delivers a voice
over narration
be kind for everyone is fighting a hard
battle and if you really want to see
what people are all you have to do is
look subscribe to watch more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching
[Music]